Welcome back. So, we will be start to discussing on semantic analysis of the sentences. So,
earlier we talked about semantic analysis of the words. Now, we should elevate ourselves
to the sentence level. So, here we have the sentence Jyoti Drob Jai from Kharagput to
Kolkata in her kia-seldo and we have another sentence the stone clogged the rain pipe right.
Now, you see that the different words that have been marked in different colors, they
have certain relationship semantic relationships with the main verb of the sentence Drob or
drive ok. So, here the main verb of the sentence the second sentence is clogged right. The
kind of semantic relationship that you are talking about agent, some entity that performs
an action, patient, some entity which is a kind of recipient or affected by some action.
Source is a kind of whenever there is a kind of movement activity. So, what is the source
of the movement and what is the destination of the movement and finally instrument talks
about the kind of instrument by which the action was performed right.
Now, as you can easily see for the first sentence Jyoti should be tagged with the agent because
she is the one who is performing this action drive and Jai is patient, Jai is getting affected
or benefited by this action and source of this action is Kharagpur and the destination
of this action is Kolkata and of course, the action was performed through and this kia
shelters which is tagged as instrument. Now, look at this the second sentence now one may
be inclined to tag the subject of the sentence here in this case Jyoti to be the agent.
Now here the subject of the sentence is the stone though it is the subject of the sentence
you can see semantically it is not an agent, but it is a kind of instrument which has got
which has clogged the rain pipe and rain pipe is the patient right.
So, the kind of take away from this exercise is that the grammatical category may not always
lead to correct identification of the semantic roles and these relationships as you can see
these are called semantic roles. And they called semantic because they assign meaning
to the relationship between the main verb and the different constituent phrases in the
sentence and they are each of these are playing a particular role to understand the meaning
of the sentence. So, that is why these are called semantic roles.
And again there are different kind of knowledge basis which have kind of dealt with this issue
as you can see that if you think about a particular verb this verb has got different roles and
it is not like that every verb will have all the roles to it right. Some roles are relevant
for a given verb, some other roles are relevant for another verb. So, for example, if we think
about the verb sale it the relevant roles are like seller who is selling the thing.
The thing sold the buyer the price paid beneficiary right, but if you think about say cut to be
a verb. So, you cannot really have a seller to be a kind of a role which is relevant to
cut, you cannot have thing sold to be a kind of a relevant role for this verb. So, that
is why what people have done say through projects like prop bank or verb net or frame net they
have tried to assign different relevant roles for different verb groups.
Now this can be thought of as predicates in the sense that sale is the predicate and you
have say seller to be an argument thing sold to be another argument so and so forth. So,
we have a kind of predicate argument structure. So, each verb whenever it is connected to
its semantic roles the relevant semantic roles we come up with something called predicate
argument structure right. Now this is the kind of resource that people
have already created. Now what is the task? Task is given a sentence like this Al Brownstein
sold it for 60 dollar a bottle. So, this is the sentence. So, what is the task? The task
is given this sentence as input and given the predicate argument structure of the verbs
as input. First of all you have to find out which predicate would be relevant for this
sentence. For example, the sale predicate is relevant for the sentence, but this cut predicate
is not relevant for the sentence. Now after we have done that we have to tag the phrases
of the sentence with the arguments. For example, Al Brownstein has been tagged as the seller
argument 0. It has been tagged as the argument 1 which talks about thing sold and 60 dollar
a bottle has been tagged as price paid because that talks about the price of the item that
has been sold right. And you can see that given this sentence is not necessary that you have
to tag all the relevant argument roles it is not like that you have to only tag the relevant
rules right. And you see this rent has got a different structure altogether or different
set of arguments altogether. Now what they follow a different scheme, but more or less
the idea is same I am not going to the detail of it I will like to invite you to go to the
resources and check for yourself. Now the idea of semantic role labeling where
given a sentence we are trying to find out first of all which predicate argument structure
would be useful to represent the sense in the sentence. So, here we see that issued is
the verb which would be a kind of assigned a kind of verb template right. And this will
be acting as our predicate. Now the arguments are argument 0 which is San Francisco examiner
argument one is a special edition and there is a kind of temporal argument in the form
of around noon yesterday right. And this has followed the prop bank idea. So, this kind
of structure, but again if you have something called frame net we have a kind of different
kind of annotation. So, here what I am trying to project the semantic
role labeling of the sentence creeping in the shadow I reached a point when I could
look straight to the uncartain window. So, here you can see that there is a kind of action
self motion and that is that has been tagged with this verb creeping right. And there is
a kind of mover which has been marked to I and there is a kind of a path shape frame
attached to this word reached. And this has got a goal and this goal has been attached
to this entire phrase point when I could look so and so forth the entire remaining part.
Now looking has been tagged with the predicate argument structure or frame whatever you call
it. So, which has got one agent and agent is I and direction of the action because it
is a kind of perception action the direction is tagged with to this entire remaining part
like straight to the uncartain window. So, the basic idea is that again you have a set
of predicate argument structures and this predicate argument structures are also called
frame and it is easy to see why they are called frames.
So, you can see here the cell is a kind of title of the frame and it has got seller to
be a slot, you have thing sold to be another slot so and so forth. And given so this is
a kind of template or frame. So, given such a template or frame and an input sentence
you have to tag or assign values to this empty places in the slot. So, for all these slots
you have to assign the value picked up from the sentence. So, here you can see that this
argument 0 is a slot and the value that you are assigning is the San Francisco examiner
and for arg 1 again this is a kind of slot and for which you are assigning the value
as special edition. So, this is what we call as semantic role
level. Now, after we have understood the meaning of the sentence, we have to look at the level
beyond the sentence level and that brings us to the idea of discourse modeling. So, language
is a kind of phenomenon that is not only confined to this word of the sentence, but it is a
kind of collated structured and the coherent group of sentences. In a very naive sense
a kind of whenever you are talking to someone, whenever you are writing something, it is
again a coherent group of sentences. And that is what we call as a discourse which
has got a coherence. First of all it is a group of sentences and it is not on a kind
of random assortment of the sentences, they are having a structure and of course they
are coherent. And this discourse can be of two types, one is a monologic discourse, we
have a speaker here a pair and this is of course a one way communication, speaker is
speaking and the here it is listening. And of course it can be dialogic and this you
see an example of this is a kind of someone has wrote say article and you are someone
is reading that. And this dialogic discourse as you know whenever you engage in chat with
some human being or one system or assistance like Google assistance Siri or Quotano so
on and so forth. So, basically the change of the speaker and
the here all changes. Sometimes the user is the speaker, sometimes the system is the
speaker, sometimes the user is the hearer or the system is the hearer so and so forth.
So, basically it involves asking questions, giving answer, sometimes making corrections
or maybe confirming something that someone has said. So, these are the kind of acts
that we do in a dialogue. So, whenever we talk about discourse there
are two very distinct ideas, one is called text cohesion and coherence. And this distinction
is very important to understand. So, whenever we talk about cohesion, cohesion is a kind
of grammatical property. So, what do you mean by that? So, let us say you have sentences
like as I told earlier I lost my keys perhaps it has been kept in my office. So, this is
what we call as a reference and the word it refers to something some another word which
is present in another sentence. So, in that way what you are doing you are kind of attaching
two sentences together. The first sentence and the second sentence is kind of glued together
by using this kind of references, eat, these, those cards, neither something like that.
Sometimes to avoid repetition we use tools like ellipses. So, for example, in the sentence
10 students passed and another 10 failed. So, I have not repeated this. So, I could
have said 10 students passed and another 10 students failed, but that will not sound that
much good. So, what we just did we just omitted a students from here. So, again it is kind
of attaching these sentence and these sentence together. You can also use substitution to
avoid repetition. So, for example, this bulb is broken and the next sentence is give me
a new one. So, you cannot really think that the existence of the sentence give me a new
one without the existence of the first sentence this bulb is broken. So, that is how these
two sentences are glued together and in contrast coherence is extra grammatical property right.
So, it is not a kind of a grammatical property. It is something to do with the understanding
of the listener or the hearer about what the speaker or the writer has said. So, it is
defined as the extent to which the reader or the listener is able to understand the writer's
communicative intentions. So, I will give some examples of course.
So, whenever we talk about discourse modeling there are three important tasks one is discourse
segmentation. So, given a long text you want to segment the text into a high level structure.
So, for example, if you think about a research paper, a research paper can be segmented into
abstract introduction related work methodology so on and so forth right.
The second task is core reference resolution and that relates to cohesion. So, for example,
if we look at the sentence the teen woodman went to the MRL city to see the wizard of
woes and ask for a heart after he asked for it the woodman waited for the wizard response.
So, as you can see that there are many references that are being made for example, he eat the
woodman the wizard and you can see this the wizard refers to the another phrase in the
first sentence right. So, that is a task the task is to find out such core references.
The third one is judging text coherence. So, here we want to check how much may be a pair
of sentences or may be a collection of sentences bind with each other.
So, if you look at the first pair of sentences like John Headebill's car keys and the next
sentence is he was drunk possibly the second sentence is providing a kind of cause for
the first sentence, but if you look at the second pair John Headebill's car keys he
likes spinach these two are no way related to each other. So, that is why these first
pair is very coherent pair, but the last second pair is not at all coherent even though they
are grammatically very correct and meaning they have some meaning. So, if you look at
discourse segmentation. So, if you can think of that text is a long sequence of tokens
may be the words right and whenever a discourse is being changed from one topic to the other
topic. So, there is a shift of shift in the vocabulary usage right.
So, can we model that right. So, the question of discourse segmentation or the task of discourse
segmentation can be solved by solving this question can topic shift be modeled as change
in lexical coherence pattern or vocabulary. So, most likely if the if you think about
the introduction of a paper. So, that we will talk about very generic thing, but if you
go to methodology section that we will talk about something different than what we discussed
in the introduction. So, as the vocabulary usage is getting changed maybe we can model
this segmentation as a change in topics. Now, whenever there is a change in topic there
will be a kind of deep in the similarity between the representation of this block and the representation
of this block. So, you can see that there might be some values like this and the value
would represent that there is a possible segmentation case right.
Whenever you talk about coreference resolution. So, we will try to find out what are the kind
of referring expressions. So, and what are the kind of reference right. So, you can see
is the pronoun and if we just look at this individual sentence it will have no meaning
unless we have a kind of a referent which can be attached to this referring expression
right. So, all these together they are called the
anophoric expression because these all four like Victoria chain her the 37 year old she
they are pointing out to the same entity Victoria chain. So, this is what we call as reference
resolution. So, given a piece of text we want to find out the set of phrases which talks
about the same entity. Now, let us look at this piece of text and
let me just run through it yesterday the delegates chose their new representatives even though
Smith received received only 24 votes he accepted the election with a short speech then the
assembly applauded for three minutes due to the upcoming caucus meeting the subsequent
discussion was very short and nevertheless nonetheless the most pressing questions could
be result the meeting was closed at seven. Now, you can see it has got a very it has
got a hierarchical structure for in the first sense for in first of all there is a kind
of sequence right. So, if you look at this one a to one d it is the first element in
the sequence then we have one e to one g this is the second element in the sequence right.
So, first element talks about he accepted the elections with a short speech then the
assembly applauded for three minutes. The second one talks about subsequent discussion
was very short and finally and the meeting was closed at 7 p.m. So, in the top level
we have a sequence of three blocks right. Now, if you narrow down to a single block.
So, here these the first sentence talks about yesterday the delegates chose their new representatives
now the second two sentences they are elaborating the first sentence a bit right giving more
information to the first statement, but the second a part like which comprises these one
b and one c it talks about like even though Smith received only 24 votes he accepted the
election with a short speech. So, there is a kind of sense of concession.
So, he accepted the short election speech which is represented by this I c, but there
is a kind of concession relationship between this first sentence and the second sentence
bit of kind of even though he has got this 24 votes right. So, the idea is that the discord
structure it is not necessary that it will always be flat or sequential there might be
hierarchy in the structure and that is what one should capture if someone wants to capture
the essence of the discord properly. Now, as I have talked about different technologies
in this natural language processing area or basically the tasks and related technologies
I will focus in the remaining part on the applications or different tasks.
So, of course, machine translation is a very important task for us it is basically automating
the process of translating takes from one language to the other language and of course,
you know there are different challenges. So, the words or the phrases in the one language
they can map to multiple words in the target language. For example, if I have this word
like I went to bank this bank may be referring to the meaning in Hindi like Nadi Kakinare
river bank or a bank in the sense of financial institution and depending on the exact sense
of the bank in which the word is appearing in the given context you need to come up with
different translation right. Sometimes the phrasal verbs are very difficult to translate
because a same phrasal verb may have may different meaning in different context. So, for example,
if I have the sentence they brought up the child in luxury. So, here the translation
of phrasal verb brought up should be a pollen portion Karna, but if you have a sentence they
brought up the table to the first floor, here we are translating brought up with Uparlana
in the third case if we have this they brought up the issue in the house here we will be
translating it with Muddha Uthana in Hindi. Sometimes there are structural ambiguities
like flying planes can be dangerous. So, it can be translated in different ways like Hawaii
Jawaj Urana Khatarnak Hosakta Hai or Urta Hue Hawaii Jawaj Khatarnak Hosakta Hai. So, depending
on how you are structurally arranging the sentence the translation would differ.
Now, if we talk about rule based machine translation systems. So, it is like translating the structure
of one language one representation to the structure of the other language representation.
So, for example, if we have the sentence in English there was a lion in the jungle. So,
maybe my if we try to get an abstract representation of this I could have write this in a way a
lion was in the jungle then I know in Hindi we would have this preposition phase in the
beginning part of the sentence we just write some transfer rule which will translate this
structure into a structure like this where I will swap different phrases across different
parts of the analysis right. So, here I am taking this in the jungle from
the last part of the tree to the first child of the tree and then we can translate directly
like jungle may a share tha right. This is what we call as transfer rule based approaches
in machine translation system. As you know these transfer rules they are pretty much
language pair dependent right. So, if you want to translate the same sentence in French
maybe you have to have some other set of transfer rules. So, that is why these kind of transfer
rule based machine translation systems are not really scalable. That is what brought
us to statistical machine translation system where the very famous idea to solve this was
to have a parallel corpora. Parallel corpora in the sense that for the same sentence we
have say English version of the sentence and let us say we are creating a English to French
translation or the French to English translation. So, we will be having the same sentence which
have got a French representation and corresponding English representation and we will be having
a huge number of such pair of sentences like that and that is what we call as the parallel
corpora parallel corpora and use that corpora to train a machine learning system or statistical
machine translation system to solve this machine translation task.
So, a very famous idea in this respect was what we call as noisy channel metaphor right.
So, what does it do? So, let us we are translating a French sentence to its corresponding English
sentence. So, the assumption is that that there is a kind of speaker who spoke in English.
So, let us say Mary did not slap the grain wedge and that was sent through a communication
channel and this communication channel is noisy which parters the tokens or the signal
and changes it right and as the result of the change the receiver will receive the French
sentence right. Now, this channel has a model in the sense
that given an English phrase what is the likelihood that this will be changed into a French phrase
right. Now, the thing that is being sent from the communicator and English sentence and
this English sentence has a kind of probability of occurrence and that is being perturbed
using this channel model and as a result we are getting the French sentence.
Now, we have to decode the English sentence from what we have observed in the form of
the French sentence. So, that is the kind of challenge right. So, what we will try to
do? We will try to maximize these probability quantity like probability E and probability
F given E and then to find out the English sentence which maximizes this product right.
So, this is one way how the machine learning problem machine translation problem was solved.
Now, in the modern time we are using this neural machine translation models. So, again
what we have? We have a source sentence here we are translating an English sentence in
this corresponding French sentence in the earlier example it was the reverse.
So, we are trying to come up with representation of this sentence maybe in the token level
or maybe the entire sentence level. So, depending on which kind of architecture you are using
the strategy may vary. But the basic essence is that the encoder provides some information
from this encoder block and this is going to the decoder block and what the decoder does
it starts with the start symbol and produces the corresponding French translation tries
to produce the corresponding French translation. And whatever that is has been produced that
will be used in the next decoding state right. So, basically what this state will do it will
take the encoder state at that point of time or sorry the decoder state at that point of
time and the previously output token and it will try to produce the next token right.
And again as I said that it is not it the strategy varies across the architecture I
hope this kind of architectures will be talked about in detail in the subsequent lecture,
but that is why I am not going into detail of this. So, idea is that nowadays this is
being solved using this neural machine translation models, neural models.
The next task that I will talk about is question answering where you have a precise question
like when was the premiere of the magic flute. So, this was the question and there is a set
of index documents which potentially may contain the answer for this question. And there will
be a retriever will retrieve a set of documents relevant to this question and what there might
be different approaches, one approach is to use the large language models directly.
What we can do you can put the docs and prompt and the query to the large language model
and it will generate the answer or you can feed the questions along with the retrieved
documents to a model like BRT and what this BRT will do it will select the document and
for the document it will mark the tokens which might be the potential answers.
Now, the next comes the transformer moment as I told you earlier it has revolutionized
the NLP field as well as the other fields as well. Again I will not going I am not going
to the details of the architecture they will be taken care of I think in the subsequent
lectures. The basic point is that this architecture this transformer architecture is a kind of
baseline of different models like BRT or T5 or decoder only architectures like GPTs and
I think all the current large language models or the foundation models they are making use
of this kind of transformer based architecture. And these so now as we know that we are living
in the age of large language models it has got to us various affordances.
We can use a pretend model which are being released by different organizations and we
can fine tune them using very small amount of data to solve our specific task. And we
know this large language models are few short learners so that means, we can provide a small
number of examples that will demonstrate what we actually want the LLMs to do for us and
the LLM will try to provide answer even though this LLM is not specifically trained to solve
that particular task. And in that respect this in context learning
and prompt engineering has become very popular, but being said that these large language models
they really suffer from has suffered from bias and toxicity they may not always give
you correct information. There might be bit of privacy in some cases and most concerning
thing is the environmental concern because this large language models are very huge and
to power them you have to supply feed them with huge amount of energy.
So that is why in some cases you want to come up with small language small large language
models that will try to solve similar tasks with similar performance and accuracy. And
to in order to tackle this bias toxicity or hallucinations nowadays people talk about
model alignment. So, to align the this large language models to the human behavior where
these behaviors will try to get rid of this issue of bias toxicity or hallucination kind
of issues. So, the revolution started back in 2017 in
the form of transformer and it is rapidly taking space with invention of newer and newer
or release of newer and newer architectures and you know nowadays Deepseek has created
huge amount of noise in the community. Well, to summarize we started with something
called ELISA which was the computer program written by MIT researchers and at that point
of time it was kind of acting as a proxy of a psychologist which can understand people's
behavior and try to counsel them. People thought that they have got a very nice program which
understands the human behavior, but finally it is nothing but a kind of pattern matching
machine. And nowadays we are talking about similar kind of effect in the form of these
large language models. We are thinking that they are exhibiting human like behavior we
are kind of going towards these artificial general intelligence, but again that has to
be taken with a pinch of salt. So, we are really far away from that achieving that.
So, with that I will just point you out to the resources. The books are like the go-to
books are like speech and natural language processing by Zurabski and Martin and natural
language processing by Jacob Einstein and there are different tools which you can make
use of. I have not kept these resources for large language models. I think I have given
those references in my other lecture where I talked about inference with pre-train models
and of course there are many other resources to talk about those.
So, yeah, I am done. Thank you very much for your kind attention. I think we can go with
the question answers. The question is if I want to extract thermoelectric property value
of inorganic materials from literature what model will work for it and how to extract
it. So, there are various answers to that. So, let us say you can use a BRT kind of model
where you can have this BRT model pre-tained with similar kind of data sets. For example,
you can think of cyber embeddings which can be a good starting point and using that model
perhaps you can create a very small amount of data set where you have different articles
and you have say manually tagged some of the properties of this inorganic materials and
fine tuned the BRT model using that small amount of data and it is basically similar
to what we call as named entity cognition tasks where you can really identify the beginning
and end of the property values. And also you can think of solving this using
large language models where you can provide the chunk of text and perhaps you can tell
the large language model from the large language models how you are really thinking to extract
the properties and this large language models can do it for you for the subsequent new articles.
Next question please, how the semantic related words are decided? Would it be updated during
the run time or is it particular to a particular for the given model and would not change over
the time? So, again I have two answers to that. So, we are going for a knowledge based
approach. So, there everything has been pre specified. So, for example, the senses the
words that are coming to that appearing in that sense or categorized in that sense in
the wordnet they are already fixed right and the structure of the wordnet is already fixed.
So, in that case you cannot really update them during run time, but if you are following
this distributional hypothesis based approach or in the modern time if you are looking at
this context representation based approaches where you can feed a sentence to us a BART
model which it can come up with context dependent representation of the words.
In that case you can see that the meaning meaning in the sense of the vector representation
of the word changes run time and it depends on the context. If NLP models do not store
generated language then are they going to train on user input later on because I have
seen Google assistant asking for samples to improve their models ok.
So, in many cases people use generated language to and feed that to train the system more,
but I think the point that is relevant for your question is reinforcement learning with
human feedback. So, here for a given task let us say the model has generated some text
and the system asks for your input on that and based on your input the system will try
to align its behavior and that tries to reflect your preferences right and that is how this
generated language might be used and they are being used in some way or other.
How are punctuation marks like comma semicolon used by NLP models to resolve ambiguities arising
at word and sentence level ok. So, punctuations are very important queues to queues or clues
that provides information to the NLP systems like the punctuation sometimes they can dictate
the end of phrase for example right. So, they have got different kind of usages and if we
are going back to the earlier NLP days these punctuations they also have some presence in
the grammatical rules and based on the appearance in the rules they can be consumed by the NLP
systems, but again nowadays you are with this embedding based approaches where the embedding
concerning this common semicolons they are also used to deal with the demarcation of
the tokens or end of some token or start of some token so and so forth ok. I think we
have no more questions. Thank you all for your patience yeah thanks.